Google Compute Engine is a great
place for running Hadoop
to solve your big
data challenges.
Compute Engine runs on
Google's advance
infrastructure, developed
through 14 years of experience
building high performance web
services, supporting billions
of queries per day.
So you'll get consistent I/O
performance from Compute
Engine that scales out
predictably, which is
extremely helpful when you're
developing solutions with big
data tools like Hadoop.
I'm going to walk you through a
demo of setting up Hadoop on
Compute Engine using a sample
application from our Google
Cloud Platform repository
on GitHub.
Hadoop is an open source
implementation of the
MapReduce paper published
by Google.
Google has been using MapReduce
for many years to
distribute data processing
workloads over large clusters
of machines.
Today, we're going to show how
to process 255 gigabytes of
text to compute the number of
times each word appears in our
data set, and then output
the results in a
sorted list using Hadoop.
First, we'll download the Hadoop
getting started sample
from GitHub.
This sample sets up a Hadoop
cluster on Compute Engine that
executes a MapReduce task.
To download the sample, simply
run that git command from
within the directory
where you'd like to
download the sample to.
Once we've got the sample
downloaded, we'll cd into the
solutions Google Compute Engine
cluster for Hadoop directory.
Next, we'll need to make sure
that we've got the necessary
prerequisites to work with
Compute Engine and Hadoop.
The first tool we need to set up
for use is gcutil, which is
a command line tool
for interacting
with Compute Engine.
Follow that URL to download and
install gcutil, then open
up the readme.mb file that's
included with the Hadoop
sample and find the
gcutil section.
Follow those instructions to set
up the default project and
SSH keys to be used by gcutil.
The other tool that we'll be
using is gsutil, which allows
us to run commands on Google
Cloud Storage.
Follow the URL you see
on the slide to
download and install gsutil.
Once we've got gcutil and gsutil
installed, we're ready
to set up our Hadoop cluster.
First, we'll need
to download and
install the Hadoop package.
Let's do that now.
You can see that when I run an
ls command, that I'm currently
in the sample directory, which
is where we'll run the
following curl command to
download the Hadoop package.
Then, we'll extract the
downloaded Hadoop package
using the tar command.
Then we'll apply a patch that's
included with the
Hadoop sample.
And finally, we'll update
the package again
using the tar command.
Next, we'll download the Open
JDK and dependent packages.
To begin this step, let's
create a folder called
deb_packages under the root
directory of the sample and
then cd into that directory.
The sites where you can download
these dependent
packages from are listed in
the sample's readme file,
under the section titled
Download Open JDK and
Dependent Packages.
Listing the files in
deb_packages, you should see a
similar list of six files once
you've completed this step.
This sample uses a Google Cloud
Storage bucket from
which Compute Engine instances
will download the Hadoop
package and generated files
for the Hadoop setup.
Here's a short gsutil command
you can run to create a bucket
for this purpose.
Be sure that the bucket is
created in the same project in
which we'll be running
the Hadoop cluster.
Notice that I'm specifying the
-l flag with a value of
US-CENTRAL2.
Doing so ensures that our cloud
storage bucket will be
created in the same region as
our Compute Engine instances
that will be running Hadoop.
This way, our data transfers
across both services will be
extremely fast, and we take
advantage of the Google Cloud
platform's capability of free
data transfers between cloud
services in the same region.
Next, we'll set up our client
ID and client secret, which
will be used to access the
Compute Engine API.
Go to cloud.google.com/console
and click on the APIs and Auth
section to create a registered
app for your project.
Then open the file
gce_cluster.py in an editor
and replace the values for
CLIENT_ID and CLIENT_SECRET
with the values that you just
created in the Cloud Console.
We have a few more dependencies
that we'll need
to have in place for our Hadoop
cluster, which you can
find listed in the sample's
readme file under the section
titled Download and Set
Up Python Libraries.
Just follow the step by step
instructions there to get the
Python API client library
ready to use.
Now that we've got everything
in place, we're ready to
create a Hadoop cluster using
the sample application.
The main script of the sample
is a Python file,
compute_cluster_for_hadoop.py.
To get familiar with the
commands available, you can
run this script with
the --help flag.
This script has four
subcommands--
setup, start, mapreduce,
and shutdown--
which we'll test
out right now.
Starting with the setup command,
we'll run compute
cluster for Hadoop setup,
followed by our project ID and
the name of our Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
The setup command creates an SSH
key used for communication
between Hadoop instances.
It also uploads the Hadoop
package and its dependencies
to Google Cloud storage so that
Compute Engine instances
can download them to
set up Hadoop.
Running setup also creates a
firewall in the Compute Engine
network to allow users access
to the Hadoop web consoles.
OK, now that the setup process
has completed, we're ready to
start up our Hadoop cluster.
We can do that by running the
compute cluster for Hadoop
script with the start
subcommand, followed by our
project ID and the name of our
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
After that, we can specify the
number of instances we'd like
to start up in our
Hadoop cluster.
By default, it starts
six instances, one
master and five workers.
Let's bump that up to
97 instances and
start up the cluster.
And the startup process
is complete.
That took roughly 8 and 1/2
minutes, pretty fast for
starting up a 97-node cluster
with Hadoop ready for use.
The startup process returns a
response which includes links
to the HDFS Console and
the MapReduce Console.
Here's the HDFS NameNode
Console, which shows that the
Hadoop file system is running as
expected, with all 97 nodes
that we created.
And here's the MapReduce
Console, where we can monitor
our MapReduce jobs as
they're running.
With our Hadoop cluster up and
running, we can now start our
MapReduce job.
Using the compute cluster for
Hadoop script, we'll run the
mapreduce subcommand and pass
it the following values.
First, we'll specify the project
ID, followed by the
Cloud Storage bucket which will
be used for temporary
storage while our MapReduce
is running.
Next, we'll specify an input,
which is a Cloud Storage
bucket where our input
file or files reside.
This bucket currently contains
the results of a Hadoop
MapReduce that I ran previously
to pull out a
subset of English titles
for every object in the
255-gigabyte Freebase source
file that Google has made
publicly available.
So this input bucket now holds
a single large text file with
nearly 200,000 titles,
formatted with one
title on each line.
The output value is a Cloud
Storage bucket where the
results of our MapReduce
will be placed.
For the mapper, we'll specify
the shortest-to-longest-mapper
Python program, which is
located in the sample
directory of our sample
application.
For the reducer, we'll
specify the
shortest-to-longest-reducer
Python program.
The next value we'll pass to
the mapreduce subcommand is
the number of mappers, which
we're setting here as 95.
Finally, since we want a single
file containing our
MapReduce results,
we'll specify a
reducer count of one.
Now let's run the command
to start our MapReduce.
And now our MapReduce job has
completed, and it only took
two minutes to run.
We can open up the Cloud
Storage bucket that we
specified as the output location
in our mapreduce
command to see the results
of our MapReduce job.
And there's our output file.
Let's open the file to
see the results.
And there we are.
Here's our word count results,
with the words listed from
shortest to longest and
in alphabetical order.
Excellent, success.
Now that our work is done,
the final step is to
shut down the cluster.
Jumping back to the terminal
window, we can easily do that
by running the compute cluster
for Hadoop script with the
shutdown subcommand and
specifying our project ID.
There, the cluster is
now shutting down.
So we've now seen the process of
setting up a Hadoop cluster
on Compute Engine using the
Getting Started sample.
We also saw how to use the
sample to run a MapReduce job
that processes a large data set
and generates a result.
Using the Hadoop sample
application as a starting
point, we've got all the pieces
in place to begin using
Hadoop on Google's powerful
infrastructure.
Thank you for watching.